Hey Lisa, it's Kip.
We should chat on the phone sometime soon, smiley face.
That's not a smiley face.
That's a winky face.
You're gonna e-mail her your phone number and think that's gonna get you somewhere.
Why didn't he ask for my number, though?
He must have a pager.
You obviously don't understand women.
What I just did was brilliant.
I can't call him right away 'cause that'd be weird and...
...I can't respond right away because then he'd be like, "Why didn't you just call me?"
I made the first contact, that's aggressive.
And then I just gave her my contact for my phone.
That's like, whatever, I don't care.
Oh wait hold on, I got an e-mail. It looks like it's Lisa.
Let's open that.
All right.
Oh well, she e-mailed me her number.
But before... hey, shut up.
So, should I call him?
No.
So then what am I supposed to do?
You can't call him.
Text before call.
You don't go from e-mail to phone call.
You go from e-mail to text to third-party messenger.
How about, "Hey Lisa, yo what's up?"
No, keep "yo" out of this.
"Hey, Lisa."
"Hey, Lisa." That's a good start.
"Hey Kip, it's Lisa. How you doing?"
"How are you doing?"